hello everyone welcome to part six in
our series on distributed word
representations this can be considered
an optional part but it's on the
irresistibly cool idea of retrofitting
vectors to knowledge
graphs here are central goals on the one
hand as we've seen distributional
representations are powerful and also
easy to obtain
but they tend to reflect only relatively
primitive semantic notions like
similarity or synonymy or connotation or
relatedness
so that might feel limiting
on the other hand structured resources
like knowledge graphs while sparse and
kind of hard to obtain
support really rich learning of very
diverse semantic distinctions so the
question naturally arises can we have
the best aspects of both of these and
the inspiring answer given by
retrofitting is yes we can combine them
the original method for doing this is
due to this lovely paper faroukian all
2015 which i'm going to be giving a
brief summary of in this screencast
so here is the retrofitting model it
consists of two sums and they constitute
kind of opposing forces
imagine that we have an existing
embedding space like glove or some
embedding space that you built yourself
that's q hat
and we're learning these q i's and q j's
the term on the left is basically saying
remain faithful to those original
vectors as you learn these new vectors q
i try not to be too dissimilar from
where you started
that pressure is balanced against the
pressure on the right which is saying
make representations that look more like
the neighbors
for the current node in the knowledge
graph which is you know
defined by the set of
relations e
so two opposing pressures on the one
hand we're saying be faithful to the
original on the other hand we're saying
look more like your neighbors in the
knowledge graph
if we set alpha to one and beta to one
over the out degree for the node that
we're targeting
then we have basically balance these two
pressures
if we set alpha really large we'll
mostly want to stay faithful to the
original vectors if we set beta
comparatively very large then we'll
mostly want to look like the neighbors
in the knowledge graph and we won't
remain so tethered to the original
embedding space that we started with
this illustration kind of nicely depicts
what happens in the model the gray
vectors of the original embedding space
we have this knowledge graph that
connects the associated nodes and
because they're connected in the
retrofitting space which is given in
white these nodes are kind of pulled
together and look more
similar there's a bunch of code for
doing retrofitting in the course
repository and i'll just show you a few
quick illustrations using that code
let's start with a simple case we have a
very simple knowledge graph where node
zero is connected to node one and node
zero is connected to node two just
directionally
what happens when we run the
retrofitting model is that zero is
pulled equally close to one into two
kind of equidistant between them and
closer to both than it was in the
original embedding
here's space
situation in which every other every
node is connected to every other node
that's represented on the left here
that's where we start and as a result of
running the retrofitting model with
alpha and beta set in their default
parameters what happens is that triangle
just gets smaller and a kind of fully
symmetric way as the
nodes become more similar to each other
because of the graph structure
here's a kind of degenerate solution if
i set alpha to 0 i have no pressure to
be faithful to the original vectors all
i care about is looking like my
neighbors from the term on the right and
as a result all these vectors shrink
down to be the same point after the
model is run for a few iterations
if instead i had done the opposite of
made alpha really large comparative to
beta then basically nothing would have
happened in the learning a triangle
would remain its original size
it's worth considering some extensions
so i think one the fundamental
limitation of this model is that it is
kind of assuming right there in its
objective that had to have an edge
between nodes is to say that they are
similar but of course the whole point
might be that your knowledge graph has
very rich edge relations corresponding
to different linguistic notions like
autonomy
and we certainly wouldn't want to treat
synonymy and autonomy as the same
relation and just assume that it meant
similarity in our model
uh so there are various extensions i
think the most general extension that
i've seen is from a paper that i was
involved with led by ben lingarich which
is called functional retrofitting which
allows you to very flexibly learn
different retrofitting modes for
different edge semantics
and once you start down that road you
have a really natural connection with
the literature on graph embedding that
is learning distributional
representations for nodes and knowledge
graphs and this paper but led by will
hamilton is an outstanding overview of
methods in that space and then you have
this nice synergy between nlp methods
and methods that are more associated
with work on knowledge graphs and social
networks and so forth
and finally here are some code snippets
just showing some simple illustrations
of the short sort that i showed you
earlier in the screencast i would just
mention at the end here if you would
like to apply these methods to wordnet
which could be a powerful ingredient for
the first assignment and bake off i
would encourage you to check out this
notebook bsm03 retrofitting because it
walks through all the steps for doing
that